la sultane en russie avec sa bonhomie
avec sa gentillesse sa faconde gorille
est ce que vous l'avez senti tout de
suite ça comme quand j'avais vu le
scénario est ce que vous avez senti que
c'était un rôle très important et même
disons un peu plus important que les
autres plus importants que les autres et
fédérales ans de retard mais n'est ce
pas qui sortait de l'ordinaire est
vraiment la première fois que du vivier
m'envoyer le sujet j'étais à carry le
rouet près de marseille en vacances où
je tournais tableau crever le soir je
montais à carry-le-rouet
parce qu'on sait qu'à l'international et
divo je monte on dit je monte à baril je
monte à carry-le-rouet
même si vous descendez néanmoins
toujours en phase de toute façon de
parler
et comme je suis marié j'ai gardé
quelques satisfactions et ce jour là je
me rappelle avant dîner j'étais au bord
de la mer j'ai commencé à feuilleter le
cénacle et j'ai vu la première scène où
don camillo parler à jésus et j'ai dit à
ma femme si vraiment le sujet que je
suis en train de lire
continue comme il a commencé je crois
que je tiens le rôle de ma fille et
c'était exact ça fait que j'avais fini
dans la nuit jusqu'au bout j'ai tout lu
le lendemain les graphies lee addy
vivier la chapelle d'accord et j'ai
repris les uns gym pour seulement 15
millions
je ne m'en plains pas oui le premier
film a eu un succès extraordinaire mais
depuis il a été vu par dans le monde
entier mais en france il a eu un succès
extra les oui ça mais même en france
tous d'ailleurs si nous faisons en ce
moment le cinquième c'est parce que le
café maintenant qu'amiens monseigneur
gaillot succès nous avons fait le petit
monde dans cannes et le retourne donc
admis à la grande bagarre dont camille
d'encadrement
nous maintenons donc à millau en russie
mais naturellement nous allons jamais
fait les don camillo suivi le premier a
été une chose extraordinaire que nous ne
pourrons jamais rattrapés car le premier
fait profiter allemand de choses qui
jouer d'abord la surprise c'est ça la
surprise du personnage qu'on ne
connaissez pas la surprise de parler à
jésus est un drôle de partenaires on
savait jamais eu dans ma vie mais je
dois dire que celui là je mets ma
paresse et les scénarii djezzy forcément
là j'ai un peu retrouvé mon ma province
natale de cartes avec les comics
méridionaux les acteurs ne les dieux non
aux grands le fond de tristesse ces
enfants d'humanité malgré elle c'est un
bruit qui court on dit toujours que nous
sommes déjà en mesure un plan dont des
histoires soient surtout sur marie luce
la bible nous dit où les marseillais on
ne prend jamais au sérieux général car
je crois que nous avons beaucoup plus de
sensibilité dans cette région là
l'esprit de famille est très poussée et
ça m'a beaucoup aidé dans ma carrière
dans les films que j'ai faits avec
marcel pagnol ou d'autres n'osent pas ou
j'avais des scènes d'émotion je crois
bien que lorsque j'étais les premières
scènes mouche parler à jésus dans mon
avenir j'ai retrouvé un diposition
briller ce que j'étais à ce moment là et
comme je suis catholique
j'ai cru parler à jésus parce qu'elle
est moins instants avant c'est pour ça
je crois que j'ai été assez naturelle
dans ces scènes qui sont des années
alors pour vous fernandel la sincérité
d'une chose qui compte quand vous jouez
mais vous savez que je démarre au
théâtre au music hall à sa série de la
première des choses je rentre dans votre
métier
c'est varié et dans tous les domaines il
ya d'abord une chose qui compte aussi
c'est là c'est fait
soyez sympathique bien vous pardonnera
beaucoup de choses c'est ce qui m'est
arrivé
monsieur faire un thème vous nous disiez
il ya un moment dans nos nombre
incalculable de films que j'ai faits
est-ce qu'on peut quand même de calculer
ou connaître ce nombre